[Musique]
messieur dames bonjour nous interviewons
aujourd'hui pour une chaîne Youtube qui
s'appelle servview nous avons quelques
questions à vous poser concernant la loi
numérique la stratégie européenne et la
loi de renseignement on va commencer par
la loi renseignement Axel le maire vous
êtes secrétaire d'État attaché au
numérique qu'est-ce que vous pouvez nous
en dire alors vous m'aviez dit qu'on
allait commencer par le projet de loi
numérique parce que moi jeux bien vous
parler des sujets dont j'ai la totale
maîtrise nous sommes au ministère de
l'économie et des finances n'est pas un
ministère régalien c'est pas le
ministère de la défense ni le ministère
de l'Intérieur ce n'est pas non plus la
Chancellerie euh et donc ce projet de
loi numérique il me tient énormément à
cœur parce que moi j'aimerais qu'on ait
un beau texte législatif qui place notre
pays dans une perspective de liberté
d'innovation et qui le prépare pour
l'avenir et il y aura notamment un
chapitre important autour de la de la
data de la data sous plusieurs formes de
l'Open Data euh il s'agit de de
transposer une directive européenne dans
le secteur de l'Open Data et d'aller
plus loin en droit français pour
vraiment inciter l'ensemble des acteurs
publics et économiques à ouvrir le
qu'est-ce qui va garantir le fait que
l'ouverture de ces données soit encadré
pour respecter la la la vie privée des
gens les données personnelles des gens
alors c'est l'autre type la la le
processus d'ouverture des données
publiques là je parle des données
publiques il est euh encadré par deux
autorités administratives que sont
laacnil et la CADA la commission d'accès
aux documents administratif et on va
modifier leur mission et leur champ
d'intervention pour s'assurer que tout
ça est fait bien dans les for quel type
de modification vous allez apporter ça
c'est l'Open Data les deuxième type de
catégorie de données sont les données
personnelles les données personnelles
elles sont très protégées en France la
législation française est une des
législations les plus protectrices du
monde je suis pas d'accord avec vous
dans le sens où moi je peux avoir accès
au au fichier des cartes électorales
pour 2 €. et sur le fichier des cartes
électorales je peux savoir le lieu de
naissance des gens et si je suis par
exemple un terroriste à tendance extrême
droite je peux savoir et cibler en moins
de 24 heures l'ensemble de la population
Marrakech l'ensemble de la population
marocaine née à Marrakech même si
naturalisé français comme je peux avoir
accès à leur lieu de naissance je peux
avoir ça pour 2 € à mon sens ce n'est
pas assez sécurisé vous voulez donc là
vous parlez du fichier électoral
n'est-ce pas et donc vous suggérez que
les candidats à une élection politique
qu'elle soit municipale départementale
régionale ou législative n''est pas le
droit d'avoir accès à leurs électeurs
comment ils font en campagne je je je ne
parle pas d'avoir accès à leurs
électeurs mais je pense que fait ce à
quoi sert le fichier électoral je pense
que laisser le fait de de laisser les le
lieu de naissance sur le fichier des
cartes électorales peut prêter un
problème h euh le je je suis pas
certaine parce que ça induirait l'idée
que si on est d'origine marocaine on est
un potentiel terroriste c'est assez
inquitant com mais par contre par contre
si vous avez quelqu'un qui veut cibler
les Marocains il peut le faire au moins
de 48 he pour 2
€ de la enfin ça s'appelle là là je vais
être pr liberté pardonnez-moi mais je
trouve que l'accès aux données c'est
fondamental et les données personnelles
elles sont euh accessible uniquement sur
consentement des particuliers c'est ça
la grande différence entre la
législation française et d'autres droits
de par le monde et c'est exactement ce
qu'on veut con qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez moi je suis d'accord avec Axel je
pense que il faut
consentir à
certaines à utiliser des données
personnelles dans certains cas et à
publier parce que on considère que
l'intérêt
supérieur est plus important que le
risque encouru et je pense que le risque
encouru en ce qui concerne ce point
particulier il est quand même
relativement faible Mo bayara
ou je suis très je suis très mitigé ENF
pour moi pour moi le fichier électoral
est un fichier personnel c'est tu as le
nom le prénom des gens leur adresse leur
date de naissance enfin globalement moi
quand j'appelle mon banquier au
téléphone pour m'identifier il me
demande ma date de naissance donc enfin
ça correspond à des infos pas très
sensibles mais relativement sensibl tout
de même accessible librement ça me
paraît curieux après qu'on ait accès
éventuellement à la liste des électeurs
et leur adresse ça me paraît amplement
suffisant dans un cadre dans un cadre
électoral savoir à quelle date sont né
les gens et
où si on utilise la date c'est parce que
euh c'est la façon dont on a qu'on a de
s'assurer qu'il y a pas deux personnes
qui portent le même
nom ça c'est la façon dont
l'administration gère le fichier il y a
aucune raison que ces données soient
publi
euh auune Rais après il y a le risque de
dire que dans la mesure où c'est pas
publique on n pas une garantie que c'est
les mêmes et qui a potentiellement eu
bidouillage de fichiers et cetera donc
c'est quand même aussi de s'appuyer sur
les forces citoyennes pour je dirais
avoir un notre pouvoir à l'égard de
c'est pas public hein on signe une
décharge enfin une décharge sappelle pas
comme ça on on on s'engage à
respecter la confidentialité des données
qui sont incluses dans le registre
électoral lorsqu'on lui demande on
demande accès à une préfecture par
exemple à ce fichier et on s'engage
aussi à ne pas l'utiliser à des fins
commerciales moi j'ai beaucoup vu les
différences de pratique électorale entre
la France et le Royaume-Uni aux
États-Unis c'est encore plus le libre
marché des des données on voit bien
enfin là tout récemment il y a eu des
élections en Angleterre les partis
politiques se sont rués sur les données
des électeurs pour utiliser des des
calculs algorithmiques qui ont permis de
mieux cibler les le les les poches de de
potentiel votant pour un parti plutôt
qu'un autre bon en France on fait pas ça
parce qu'on a pas le droit de le faire
on n pas le droit de faire du croisement
de fichier en revanche que un candidat à
une élection et la liste de ses
électeurs enfin ça s'appelle la
démocratie hein l'arbitrage entre les
encore une fois les données personnelles
et les données en accès ouvert et et
public il est délicat à trouver mais
dans cet arbitrage le droit français est
beaucoup plus protecteur que les autres
droits et c'est exactement ce qui se
négocie à Bruxelles en ce moment on
essaie d'harmoniser le marché européen
des données personnelles pour que que
une entreprise par exemple qui a qui qui
s'installe en Europe puisse utiliser les
données à l'échelle du marché européen
c'est une immense demande de la part des
entreprises quel est le pays quel est le
pays qui a le niveau d'exence le plus
élevé bien plus élevé que l'Allemagne
qui est en coalition politique et où on
voit que ça flagelle sur certain né mais
c'est la France c'est la France parce
qu'on a laacnil la Commission Nationale
Informatique et Liberté qui a été créé
en 1978 bien avant l'arrivée d'Internet
et parce que cette tradition de
protection des données personnel elle
est très ancrée dans l'histoire
institutionnelle vous êtes vous êtes
blogueur méamédia et précaution oratoire
vous ne vous exprimez pas au nom de
France Télévision non non mais au nom de
de mon blog de France Télé non mais vous
travaez chez france télé c'est ça
directeur de la stratégie de la
prospective France Télé stratégie
numérique oui non pour pour faire écho à
à exel le ma effectivement on fait nous
de notre côté on essaie de faire très
très attention à aux données on a on a
mis en place on a essayé de mettre en
place affichage il TR affichage une
politique data friendly une charte une
charte des données ah bon une charte des
données on éta les premiers en France à
le faire en Europe aussi en tout cas
parmi les grands médias pour pour
justement permettre au
télénotes de dire de leur dire de leur
donner le choix est-ce qu'on partage
avec des des annonceurs où est-ce qu'on
met les données combien de temps les
garde leur donner des conseils si on a
des soucis nous de avec des petits qui
viendrait chercher nos
serveurs voilà ce type de chos essayer
de donner une protection supplémentaire
et en tout cas une liberté autour des
données des utilisateurs de de français
vision en ligne Éric Léandri vous êtes
directeur général du moteur de recherche
français quant oui vous avez comme
valeur de protéger la vie privée de vos
utilisateurs votre avis sur la
protection des données en France en
Europe et puis dans le monde peut-être
je vais rebondir sur tout ce qui a été
dit depuis tout à l'heure sur lesnil je
suis complètement d'accord c nous depuis
le début on s'est appuyé sur les kil
européennne et les obligations de kil
européennes pour monter le moteur et
garder la data qu'on avait le droit de
conservé c'est-à-dire absolument rien si
on ne demande pas aux gens parce qu'on
est en optine en Europe et donc à partir
de là
si en France en Allemagne dans d'autres
petits pays ça dépend comment on gère le
truc donc donc aujourd'hui le fait de
pouvoir harmoniser tout ça sur les deux
plus sévère Allemagne et France en fin
de compte c'est pour nous quelque chose
de très bien et le fait d'avoir un seul
marché européen au niveau d'chnil c'est
quelque chose de vraiment très
intéressant parce que moi aujourd'hui je
suis obligé de gérer pour la France mais
aussi pour l'Allemagne mais aussi pour
l'Italie mais aussi pour l'Espagne donc
on dépense un peu d'argent avec nos
avocats pour avoir des ciles dans dans
les pays ça vous pose un problème est-ce
que ça vous affaiblit le fait de de
d'être obligé d'investir de l'argent au
début forcément on joue sur internet il
jouent les Américains aussi en optout et
d'autres pays hein mais on va commencer
par les US donc on joue sur le même
terrain de jeu mais eux ils jouent au
football américain nous c'est des pieds
le football donc bon c'est pas super
efficace et donc on est passé au règles
du rudby avec des petites astuces mais
en fait on a transformé un problème en
valeur et on a transformé un problème en
solution donc aujourd'hui c'est ce qu'on
a fait aujourd'hui et l'idée globale
derrière ça c'est de garantir plusieurs
choses premièrement la garantie que nos
utilisateurs ne vont pas être traqués
chez nous alors évidemment faut faire de
la publicité mais j'ai un avantage on
est moteur de recherche c'est quand même
beaucoup plus facile que pour vous parce
que nous on a la demande s'il demande
d'iPad on peut leur montrer du shopping
sur iPad donc c'est pas c'est pas qu'on
a des oies blanches hein vous vous avez
un autre problème vous savez pas qui
arrive mais la chose la plus importante
pour nous c'est ne pas traquer garantir
la confidentialité garantir la
confidentialité des requêtes donc suivre
toutes ces obligations qui avaient été
mis en place par lescil aujourd'hui on a
quand même un petit problème par rapport
à tout ce que j'entends depuis tout à
l'heure je trouve que la donnée
personnelle il y a juste un problème
dans ce mot personnel c'est la donnée
pour moi elle doit être libre c'est
parfait d' avoir cette idée d'Open Data
c'est génial l'étendre c'est parfait
même demander à des privés de voir s'ils
sont prêts à échanger de la donnée ben
pour nous en tout cas on annonce dès
aujourd'hui qu'on est prêt à échanger
tout ce qu'on indexe sur le web tout ce
qu'on indexe sur le web social avec des
AP ouvertes avec plaisir pour que ça
crée de l'emplo ça crée c'est en fait on
va dire une partie logicielle qui va te
permettre de faire des appels et
récupérer de la donnée du flux de
données mais je pense que tes tes
interlocuteurs le savent tous donc pas
de souci là dessus et donc à partir de
là cette cette interface ce protocole va
nous permettre de donner de la donnée
mais plus intéressant que ça on peut
donner de la données mais dès qu'on
parle de données personnelles là nous on
a un problème pourquoi parce que pour
faire du machine learning et revenir sur
la santé sur les infos ou même sur les
listes électorales il est normal qu'on
ait accès aux listes pour savoir s'il y
a des morts ou pas dans les listes je
suis cor je peux en parler des listes un
peu bizarres pas de souci particulier je
comprends très bien de quoi ça parle
très très bien mais en dehors de ce
point précis si on revient au au
problème la donnée personnelle elle a un
caractère qui est personnel donc pour
faire du machine learning pour faire de
de la compréhension même pour savoir ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui sur Internet ou
ce que cherchent les gens on peut
anonymiser tout ça très facilement et on
peut donner cet accès simplement sur
vraie demande pour vérification très
facilement aussi donc je pense moi qu'il
y a une petite erreur si elle est
personnelle elle est personnelle on peut
donner de la donnée pour des bases
statistiques pour savoir s'il y a plus
de cancer autour de Paris ou en Corse
après le passage de Tchernobyl ou pas ça
c'est des choses qui ont du sens mais
est-ce qu'il y a besoin de savoir si
c'est chez moi si c'est chez vous si
c'est votre enfant parce que là on parle
de nous on est adulte mais c'est la même
pour nos enfants c'est le même problème
ils ont rien demandé à personne ils
peuvent pas se défendre aujourd'hui donc
je pense qu'on peut anonymiser tout ça
et on va obtenir quasiment les mêmes
résultats en faisant du travail de
machine learning et de Data sur de la
donnée qui n'est pas justement de la
donnée personnelle ce qui
m'intéresserait de savoir mais de la
part des techniciens je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec cette distinction il y a
les données personnelles et il est
essentiel de respecter la vie intime la
vie privée et les données sont le reflet
de la vie privée et puis l'Open Data ce
sont des données publiques qui sont
ouvertes et mises en accès libre mais
qui sont bien sûr anonymisés moi ce
qu'on me dit et ce que m'expliquent les
techniciens c'est qu'en fait
l'anonymisation elle est
limitée c'est-à-dire qu'elle est elle
est elle est pas totalement possible
parce que à partir du moment on fait du
Big Data où on utilise des mégaadonnées
où on mélange et ben on peut refaire
sortir des profils vous savez comment on
peut repersonnaliser les données et
c'est là que moi j'ai une source
d'inquitude en mettant simplement une
boîte noire ou quelque chose
supplémentaire qui casse le fait qu'on
avait anonymiser les
choses non mais c'est pas le problème
c'est en fait il suffit il suffit qu'il
ait il suffit qu'il y ait un lien ce
lien vous permet ensuite de tirer le fil
mais un lien c'est très compliqué à
obtenir un lien pour un exemple très
simple je vais prendre chez moi
j'anonymise à l'entrée j'anonymise l'IP
je ne mets pas de cookies je ne profile
rien et je ne garde rien à part les
queries alors je sais qu'il y a eu sur
des millions de quiries dans la journée
ou desou une dizaine de millionsou 12
millions de quiries dans la journée je
sais qu'il y a eu allez je vais dire
n'importe quoi 500000 personnes qui ont
cherché Paris
super je sais aussi qu'ils ont cliqué
ensuite pour sortir vers tel endroit
pour sortir ce soir 30000 ont cliquer
sur un truc pour sortir 50000 ont cliqué
sur un truc pour aller visiter le Louvre
et ainsi de suite super ce que je peux
dire c'est que des gens veulent visiter
Paris dans dans mes utilisateurs ce que
je peux dire c'est qu'ils sont plutôt de
culture ou plutôt dans les soirées ou
plutôt pour quelque chose d'intéressant
ce que je ne peux pas dire c'est si
c'est Gill exactement mais ça c'est la
loi françise
qui sauf je vais aller juste après moi
je ne suis qu'un petit maillon du truc
et quand il sort de chez moi et qu'il
arrive chez le voisin là d'un coup il a
le cookie du voisin il a les infos du
voisin Benjamin Bayard et puis ensuite G
l'anonymisation en fait c'est qu'on
utilise un mot qui désigne deux concepts
au départ on a une donnée nominative
c'est qu'on a une donnée qui nous dit
par géolocalisation du téléphone
portable Axel le maire arrive à Berille
à 8h12 on repart à 13h23 et cetera ça
c'est une donnée purement nominative il
y a deux façons de l'anonymiser soit on
enlève le nom et on dit un téléphone
arrive à 8h12 un autre téléphone repart
à 13h23 et on ne sait pas si c'est le
même on a enlevé le nom et ça làdedans
il y a une pate d'
qu'on est pas capable de dire la
personne qui est arrivée à 8h12 est
restée pendant 5h donc on a vraiment
perdu l'information on a perdu la
corrélation entre les données ou bien on
remplace le nom par un identifiant et si
on remplace le nom par un identifiant
alors on a gagné on peut désanonymiser
en gros à partir de 7 à 8 données c'est
la personne qui est arrivée à telle
heure repartie à telle autre qui est
arrivée ensuite à tel endroit et qui
part tous les matins de telle ville
c'est forcément AEL le maire ça peut pas
tre quelqu'un d'aut c'est exactement
exactement ce sur quoi on s'oppose en ce
moment à Bruxelles dans la dans la
négociation sur le projet de règlement
sur les donné personnell pour moi il y a
deux il y a deux infos clés dans les
histoires de données personnelles il y a
d'abord faire de l'anonymisation
convenable c'est-à-dire pas remplacer le
nom par un identifiant mais supprimer le
nom oui on perd l'information et oui on
peut moins bien corréler et du coup les
analyses statistiques sont moins fines
mais voilà c'est le prix des libertés ça
c'est le premier le premier élément et
pour moi il y en a vraiment un deuxième
clé qui existe déjà en droit français
qui est pas respecté qui est l'accès aux
données
euh la loi Informatique et Liberté dit
que j'ai accès aux données que à peu
près n'importe qui a dans un fichier
avec mon nom associé et c'est pas vrai
je sais d'expérience ayant travaillé
chez les opérateurs que quand la police
demande la géolocalisation de mon
téléphone elle l'obtient alors que quand
moi je la demande à mon opérateur je ne
l'obtiens pas pour quelle
raison parce que du coup là c'est parce
que la loi n'est pas appliquée alors
c'est un là aussi un très bon exemple
parce que parce que moi je voudrais
renforcer l'effectivité du droit d'accès
aux données parce que en réalité il
devrait suffire d'avoir une application
sur son smartphone par laquelle on sait
exactement qui a des données sur moi et
quel type de données quelle quantité et
avoir directement par l'application le
droit de modifier ses données comme la
loi Informatique et Liberté nous y
autorise mais c'est plus un problème
d'effectivité d'applique tion la lo que
le cadre réglementaire mais c'est on
parlait du projet de loi numérique moi
j'aimerais travailler sur cette
effectivité là sur la manière de
renforcer son efficacité en fait
aujourd'hui beaucoup de choses qui sont
été évoqué je revenir sur TR notions la
première c'est ce qu' évoqué er qui sont
les learning machin je pense que
effectivement le principe initiale de la
loi de 78 ne tient plus parce que je
n'ai plus besoin de savoir si les gens
sont des num numéos ou des noms
c'estàdire que ce qui m'intéresse c'est
le comportement des gens c'est ça que je
cible je peux dire tous les gens qui
sont des barbus à lunett m'intéressent
et je veux les cibler et je n'ai pas
besoin de savoir si c'est des numéros ou
des noms et ce sont des choses qui vont
être de plus en plus aisé notamment
lorsque on sera dans des travaux de
corrélation et je pense que la
législation qu'il s'agisse du un
règlement de du texte de 78 ou dans une
certaine mesure du règlement qui est
actuellement en discussion à Bruxelles
ne parvient pas à gérer ces aspects là
parce que on essaie d'avoir des
principes qui sont génériques et ces
principes ne fonctionnent pas et je
crois que d'une façon générale ça nous
ramène finalement à ces principes et ces
autorités administratives qui me
semble-t-il sont amenés à réguler la vie
des gens moi je trouve anormal que des
autorités qui sont des extracts du
principe démocratique soit amenés à
décider finalement de la possibilité du
er le nire le numéro d'identifiant euh
de sécurité sociale pour euh décider
qu'on peut pas utiliser ça comme système
unique au sein du système de santé ils
sont revenus dessus ou encore de décider
que on ne peut pas avoir de
rapprochement entre les données fiscales
et les données social euh parce que
évidemment ça serait dangereux euh pour
pour les les libertés publiques ça c'est
la loi qu'il décide c'est pas une
autorité administrative indépendant
c'est avant tout un avis d'acnil qui l'a
décidé c'est la loi est repassée dessus
mais la loi c'est quand même le
législateur souverain élu par le peuple
qui représente le peuple qui décide de
ses principes et je pense pas que la
l'acnil elle régule la vie des gens
l'acnil elle est au contraire là pour
s'assurer que le cadre réglementaire qui
protège la vie des gens est appliqué et
et pour s'assurer aussi il y a un texte
précis de l'acnil ou mais l'acnil par
exemple a donné un avis défavorable sur
le dernier texte et ça n'empêche pas le
texte de passer donc mon point mon point
c'est de dire que c'est avant tout une
question d'agilité numérique des acteurs
politiques qui doivent être capables de
comprendre ce dont il s'agit ces enjeux
vont être systématique dans l'ensemble
des sujets et on a besoin d'avoir une
une véritable éducation au numérique de
la part du monde politique parce que
c'est le ré éc cherer alors moi j'ai
deux questions je voudrais juste revenir
un instant vous avez vous avez dit avec
c'est le maire c'est c'est difficile
c'est les experts vous le disent et nous
le disent aussi c'est très difficile
d'anonyiser les les données mais c'est
justement ce que reproche ces mêmes
experts à la loi sur le renseignement
très bonne transition merci donc ça moi
je voudrais avoir votre avis si
effectivement c'est difficile
d'anonymiser les données si il est
quasiment impossible de ne travailler
que sur les métadonnées on a on chope
quand même les données qu'est-ce que
vous répondez à ces experts notamment
celui de RIA par exemple alors je
vaisformuler la question sur la loi de
renseignement vous avez un certain
nombre d'experts comme le Conseil
national à la magistrature certains
avocat cas certains juges certains droit
de lomiste d'ailleurs à l'échelle
européenne qui ont fait une sortie il y
a pas très longtemps considérant le loi
la projet de loi de renseignement comme
étant une atteinte flagrante au liberté
individuelle qu'est-ce que vous avez
leur
répondre alors
d'abord le travail poursuit son cours là
on est en train de parler d'un texte qui
est en cours d'examen je suis
entièrement d'accord avec vous le le le
c'est c'est en inéressant c'est voir que
ça continue d'voluer douan depuis 2010
acheté des des MSI Catchers alors que ce
n'est pas légal le Sénat n'a toujours
pas rendu de de décision et les les les
officines de renseignement s'équipent
c'est une anticipation c'est parce que
c'est cousu de fil blanc qu'est-ce que
c'est pour vous non alors bon sur les MC
Catchers je je je sais pas ce que font
les officines de renseignement et la le
gouvernement a toujours été ass sur les
impty Catchers précisément et puis après
je vais répondre à votre question
le gouvernement était assez assez clair
depuis le début il y a il y a pas de loi
sur les services de renseignement en
France c'est une anomalie démocratique
j'ai vécu très longtemps au Royaume-Uni
au Royaume-Uni il y a un cadre
législatif pour dire ce qu'ils peuvent
faire ce qu'ils ont droit de faire dans
quel cadre donc c'est avant tout une loi
qui qui protège les libertés parce que
dans son objectif politique parce
qu'elle met un cadre c'est-à-dire
qu'avant nos libertés étaaient menacées
ben avant il y avait pas de loi sur les
service de renseignement ça voulait dire
que c'est pas forcément qu'ils
agissaient dans l'illégalité c'est qu'on
ne sait pas dans quel cadre ah si c'est
pas parce qu'il y a pas de loi non il y
a une loi qui dit qu'il est interdit de
poser des micros chez les gens il y a
pas de loi qu'autorise un fonctionnaire
à le faire un fonctionnaire qui le fait
or la loi point barre ça va pas plus
loin que ça toujours est-il qu'il n'y
avait pas de loi jusqu'à présent sur les
services de renseignement en France
c'était anormal il y en a dans toutes
les grandes démocraties de ce monde et
vous savez comme moi que les débats qui
ont lieu en cour en France aujourd'hui
ils ont lieu dans à peu près tous les
pays je veux dire Canada il y a de
semaines Suisse en ce moment RoyaumeUni
pourquoi en ce moment pour RoyaumeUni
pourquoi en ce moment oui pourquoi en ce
moment d'ailleurs pourquoi est-ce qu'il
y a une homogénéisation au niveau des
pays occidentaux sur le tyre
d'interception des métadonnées au niveau
des partis j'ai droit aux explications
bêtes je t'en prie vas-y parce que les
États-Unis sont en train de sont en
train de s'empétrer dans le patriotacte
et que du coup on ne peut
plus il recule sur le patriotct et il
s'empêtre
recul çae juin c'est ça et donc les
services de renseignement européens qui
avaient l'habitude d'être abreuvés en
renseignement depuis les États-Unis ont
perdu leur sources ont perdu leur
sources donc c'est pour ça que ils ont
peur de perdre leurs sources donc ils
veulent apprendre à collecter eux-mêmes
les données allez moi je peux faire un
petit truc un truc sur la France quand
même pour avoir écouté mais un truc
sympa quand même le le pour avoir écouté
Dar snodden la dernière fois que j'étais
à Berlin puce qu'il s'exprimait pas à
Berlin à novre au cébit qui s'exprimait
directement il y a quand même un truc
bien c'est comme les services de
sécurité de renseignement français sont
très agressifs on a quand même été assez
bien protégé de nos amis américains
pendant un bon moment sur le territoire
donc il y a aussi des choses qui qui qui
sont bien efficaces et bien pratiques de
temps en temps mais pour revenir à à à
aujourd'hui les Américains reculent
alors je sais pas je vais pas faire de
choses aussi simplistes que cell-là mais
je revenir sur les autres problématiques
dont on parlait tout à l'heure et juste
pour nous on avait une force incroyable
c'est Snowden arrive on s'aperçoit de ce
qui se passe s'aperçoit ce qui se passe
dans le monde entier on s'aperçoit
surtout de la façon dont les grandes
entreprises américaines travaillent
également parce que c'est pas simplement
la NSA seule qui a fait son boulot il
faut faut arrêter faut arrêter de
simplifier tout et donc à partir de là
on s'aperçoit que nous on a une énorme
force et un énorme atout c'est qu'on
défense justement nos citoyens nos
utilisateurs nos usagers dans un espace
qui est plus compliqué parce que
l'espace européen est plus compliqué
chacun parlant une langue différente je
peux vous en parler tous les jours en ce
moment et donc résultat mais en dehors
de ça on a cet énorme Atou ce qui est
étonnant c'est que cet énorme Atou qui a
quand même coûté des milliards à
l'industrie euh Internet aux US hein
parce que quand Microsoft commence à
pleurer ou quand il pleurent tous parce
que je sais pas si vous avez vu mais
pour le Patriota il y a quelques jours
il y a une liste de de d'entreprises qui
dit qu'il faut absolument y renoncer qui
est incroyable il y a tout le monde
dedans tout le monde c'est ça va de
Google à Microsoft donc euh ça ça va de
du telco à ce qu'on veut comm ni pigeon
ni espion en France un peu mais nous au
moins on part de avant on essaie de pas
arriver à après d'ailleurs le
patririotact au final ça a amené à
écouter Angela Merkel dont je suis
certain qu'elle n'est pas une terroriste
donc à partir de là c'est c'est un peu
assez drôle au final mais pour revenir à
l'histoire ça leur a coûté beaucoup
d'argent beaucoup 49 si nous sommes
aujourd'hui capable d'avoir des clouds
aujourd'hui en Europe qui respectent les
gens de continuer à faire du bitous en
Europe qui respecte les gens c'est mais
c'est un atout énorme 49 milliards ça
veut dire que des gens ont préféré ne
pas aller sur du cloud internet utiliser
des services qui les traquaient pour
pouvoir passer à quelque chose d'autre
qui ne les traquit pas et et je trouve
moi que l'Open Data le passage de
données l'échange de données la capacité
de rechercher tout ça avec une idée qui
serait d'anonymiser proprement les
choses mais proprement c'est franchement
si on se pose oui à un moment on peut
toujours récupérer une demi-ino mais si
on a pas ni le nom ni ni l'info ni le
numéro qu'on a juste des infos globales
franchement il faudrait pouvoir le
corréler avec tellement d'informations
ou par exemple aller croller sur le web
que à tel heure vous avez terminé tel
Gill Babinet ensuite ah non moi je vois
pas du tout je pense que sur le capacité
de de recouper des informations à de
forte valeur sans avoir un identifiant
fixe euh aujourd'hui on le fait très
facilement il y a de nombreuses
expérimentations qui ont été faites aux
États-Unis et en Chine qui ont démontré
que euh avec du comportemental on
recoupait avec trois ou quatre jeux de
données très individuellement les gens
donc je crois que il faut réussir à
poser une législation qui tiennent
compte de ce potentiel làà n pas je suis
encore une fois pas du tout d'accord
pour une seule raison pour une seule
raison c'est tout simplement parce que
au début le jeu de données il est pas
anonymisé il trois quatre tro quatre
infos pour récupérer quelqu'un c'est
simplement qu'on a gardé on a gé pas
besoin d'avoir des données nominatives
alors alors on a gardé dans le
comportemental tellement d' formation
qu'elle permet d'aller très loin dans le
recou exle c'est pas c'est pas ça c'est
si tu sais ce que les gens écoutent
comme musique c'est l'exemple qui a été
donnner non
pardon non non c'est le film sur ce que
les gens regardent comme film que tu es
capable de le corréler dans le temps
avec les horaires de bureau des gens
gagner on est d'accord on s compris on a
bien gardé l'identifiant de l'individu
même si a pas
l'individu regardez ce que dit spotif ce
que dit pardon Netflix il n'y avait pas
l'individu Benjamin si tu es capable de
dire ce que quelqu'un a regardé dans le
temps c'est bien que tu as un
identifiant tu as pas forcément son nom
tu as un numéro de client ou tu as un
numéro tiré au sort correspondant tu
cherches à savoir tu fais tu pinges une
base et tu dis je cherche à savoir les
gens qui s'intéressent à tel type de
film et qui se comportent de telle façon
en
terme tout de suite tout de suite je
vous pose une petite question sur la
musique j'aimerais savoir si maintenant
avec les mouchards boîtes noires
installé chez les opérateurs admettons
que moi j'écoute de l'assassin vous
connaissez assassin assassin qui a fait
la la bande original du film la haine
j'aimerais savoir si si si j'écoute
toute la journée du rap est-ce que
l'analyse comportementale de mes
métadonné va me faire rentrer dans le
spectre du terroriste h c'est bien le
film où il y a ce gars qui saute du
dernier étage et qui en pendant qu'il
est en train de sombrer dit jusque là
tout va bien c'est ça je me dis souvent
ça dans ma vie politique jusque là tout
va bien j'aimerais j'aimerais je je vais
répondre je vais répondre à la question
ce que je trouve très révélateur en fait
c'est qu'on passe des données
personnelles par exemple d'un moteur de
recherche ou d'une messagerie
électronique au PGL renseignement pour
en revenir à Spotify et la musique et il
y a quand même un mélange qui est fait
une confusion véritablement qui est un
malentendu et je pense qu'il faut d'blé
dire qu' a le ch civil qui concerne pour
la France je peux même pas dire 66
millions de de de français parce que
notre territoire il est ouvert les gens
passent et gà des millions et des
millions d'utilisateurs des services
numériques tous les jours en France et
dans le monde voilà et
et nous travaillons à préserver un accès
libre à cet internet là et puis il y a
le domaine régalien c'est quoi le
domaine régalien c'est le champ
d'intervention du ministère minre de
l'intérieur c'est quoi l'objectif du
ministère de l'Intérieur enfin je sais
pas je suis pas là pour faire la
publicité du ministère de l'intérieur
mais il sont là pourquoi ils sont ils
sont là pour protéger les gens ils sont
là pour la sécurité des Français
d'accord non mais rappelons rappelons le
but les agents des services de
renseignement ils sont pas là pour
surveiller les gens comme une FA en soi
non mais rappelons rappelons juste ce
postulat de départ fondamamental
FAM pour parler ou après ce qu'il faut
c'est dans l'équilibre dans ce cadre là
qui est le cadre régalien avec une
mission qui vise à protéger les gens
l'état do le devoir de protéger ses
citoyens je suis
d'c parce qu'il y a beaucoup de gens qui
protestent je vouis juste je voulais
juste rappeler ça c'est trouver
l'arbitrage entre la sécurité et la
liberté sacrifier ni l'un ni l'autre P
renseignement vous me parlez des
algorithmes vous me parlez des boîtes
noires d'accord que sur la techno
elle-même sur les sondes on soit
d'accord ou pas d'accord il y a un débat
au Parlement en ce moment le le texte a
été quand même adopté à une large
majorité par l'Assemblée nationale
l'Assemblée nationale elle représente
les gens donc ce qui ce qui pour à mon
sens pour les défenseurs vous croyez
encore que l'Assemblée nationale
représente les gens ça c'est un autre
débat ça c'est un autre débat avec avec
légitimité qui qui qui veulent faire
valoir leur point de vue pour le moment
ils ont échoué à faire valoir leur point
de vue le débat continue puisque ce
texte maintenant il est dans la seconde
chambre la chambre haute et à mon sens
il va continuer d'évoluer ce texte et
d'évoluer dans quel sens d'évoluer le
sens dans le sens d'un plus grand
contrôle parce que ce dont on veut
s'assurer c'est que lorsque les services
ont des actions très intrusives pour
détecter par exemple des potentiels
terroristes et bien que ces actionsl
puissent faire l'objet d'un contrôle
d'un contrôle par une commission
indépendante qui est composée d'experts
là je je je je dis l'objectif qui est
recherché si le texte aujourd'hui n'a
pas encore atteint cet équilibre et une
satisfaction sur le contrôle il peut
aller plus loin un exemple la
l'amendement que j'ai que j'ai piloter
parce que je pense que c'était important
de faire ce travail là au moment de
l'examen à l'Assemblée nationale sur les
sur les hébergeurs donc sur les
l'utilisation des dispositifs
algorithmiques
dans les réseaux des hébergeurs
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez et en quoi
vous pensez qu'il peut être qu' peut
évoluer c'est une question ultra précise
à partir de ce cet article là de la loi
qu'est-ce que vous attendez de son
évolution don je peux donner une réponse
ultra précise mais qui est pas d'un
intérêt débordant l'article en question
c'est le 8514 qui fait référence aux
données qui sont défin
1 et qui font référence tous les deux
aux données prévues par le 8111 qui sont
supposé être les données de connexion si
on en croit ce que dit le ministre dans
l'hémicycle le seul endroit où c'est dit
dans la loi c'est pas dans l'article
l'article dit toutes informations et
document ce qui est très large c'est
dans le titre du chapitre et quand on
demande à des juristes et j'en ai
consulté d'assez brillant la valeur
normative d'un titre de chapitre la
réponse est non mais revenons quand même
au fond du sujet pour le moment mais je
suis sur le fondet dans l'intrusion donc
je je suis je suis sur le fond du sujet
euh les boîtes noires sont un dispositif
intrusif et relève de la surveillance de
masse euh alors et ce qu'il faut c'est
que ça ne relève pas de la surveillance
de masse on est on est bien d'accord
personne ne le veut le ministère de
l'Intérieur ne le veut pas et le travail
juridique qui est en cours en ce moment
c'est pour affiner pour que ça ne soit
pas une surveillance de masse pour le
coup sur ce qui est prévu chez les
hébergeurs
euh même chose les les personnes visées
sont soit celles qui sont citées à
l'article 6 de la LC soit les personnes
qui sont citées à l'article l341 du Code
des postes et communications
électronique et même chose je n'ai pas
encore trouver une interprétation
juridique précise sur quels acteurs ça
ça désigne parlez des hébergeurs c'est
ça oui non les hébergeurs de site web
non non les hébergeurs de sitite web ça
c'est assez clairement défini c'est
article 6 LCEN c'est le l341 CPCE qui
est moins clair où on arrive pas bien à
savoir quels hébergeurs de quelle
plateforme sont concernés et quels
hébergeurs de quels service c'est pas le
point qui est soulevé par les gens qui
trouvent ce texte polémique c'est sen
est un parce qu'en fait on n'arrive pas
à savoir si la quantité d'information
collectée correspond à à quelques
éléments très précis ou à quelque chose
d'extrêmement et le texte est flou de
manière systématique je continue j'ai
pas fini moi j'ai un autre problème sur
ce texte là et qui qui qui est à peu
près le contraire de ce que vous disiez
pour vous votre problème c'est le
contrôle pour moi le problème c'est pas
seulement le contrôle le problème c'est
que ce texte ne prévoit pas de
sanction et je vois pas comment un texte
peut ne pas prévoir de
sanction le ministre qui a fait éplucher
les factures détaillées du journaliste
du Monde pour trouver la source il n'est
pas en prison et ça c'est scandaleux ou
ENF c'est les sanctions il y a pas de
sanction dans ce fout il y a un contrôle
juridictionnel à partir du moment
oùe il a le Conseil d'État qui peut dire
d'arrêter mon dur il en rêve de ça mon
dur il en rêve de ça que quand il passe
devant le juge le juge lui dise tu
arrêtes non pas du tout pour moi un
fonctionnaire ou un ministre qui abuse
de ses pouvoirs doit être sanctionné le
texte ne prévoit pas de sanction mais
mais d'abord c'est faux estce que les
agents des services de renseignement ils
sont soumis à des procédures
disciplinaires sans doute beaucoup plus
pointu et intrusives elle-même que dans
d'autres dans d'autres services et c'est
légitime et c'est heureux donc bien sûr
qu'il y a des sanctions disciplinaires
et je je je vois pas pourquoi et la
sanction politique euh elle est elle est
quand même très très lourde à partir du
moment où c'est une décision du Premier
ministre qui est sous avis de de la
cncttr hein sous l'avis d'une d'une
commission indépendante sachant que
l'amendement sur les hébergeurs a levé
l'exception d'urgence et dorénavant il y
a plus d'urgence en cas de de de de
recherche de potentiel terroriste en
utilisant des algorithme on parle de on
parle de délit pénal comment on peut
parler de sanction politique on parle de
délit pénal il y a un contrôle juris
faire espionner les gens de manière
illégale c'est un délit
pénal la sanction politique c'est pour
une erreur de choix j'ai fait un mauvais
choix en tant que ministre j'ai fait un
mauvais choix économique on a planté un
truc au lieu de le redresser je suis
sanctionné par les électeurs ça c'est
c'est de la sanction politique
mais l'abus de pouvoir on est dans du
pénal enfin alors on peut réécrire la
loi informatique et liberté mais les
sanctions pénales pour non respect de la
législation sur les données personnelles
jusqu'à présent ça ne relève pas du du
du Code criminel ça ne relève pas du
code pénal
après
il y il a deux différences dans un cas
ça peut être potentiellement des des
acteurs économiques et donc de l'intérêt
économique dans l'autre ça peut être
potentiellement de de faire vraiment mal
aux gens entre guillemets c'estd que
quand on s'intéresse en matière de
renseignement à la vie privée de
quelqu'un a priori c'est pas pour lui
vendre des vacances au soleil c'est
potentiellement pour utiliser les
informations beaucoup les gens c'est que
tout ça entre les mains d'un
gouvernement totalitaire
d'un gouvernement démocque attendez
attendez on on vous a beaucoup entendu
tous les deux maintenant onend mais moi
je voudrais peut-être élargir au aux
plateformes et aux algorithmes en
général est-ce que comment on peut faire
vous avez parlé de neutralité des
plateformes à Bruxelles on essaie d'en
parler je sais pas si on y arrive
comment on fait pour aller regarder sous
le capot
des des moteurs des réseaux sociaux des
algorithmes est-ce comment on fait pour
demander des comptes aux algorithmes
aujourd'hui est-ce alors on sort de la
lo non non je on sort de la loi on
élargit un petit peu mais mais mais mais
ce sont des sujets qui qui nous
intéressent en tout cas nous médias qui
nous intéresse beaucoup parce que ce
sont de plus en plus des des des
gateekeepers de l'information publique
et il y a on a un souci sur ça
donc pardon mais soyez plus précis
demander des comptes sur quoi sur la
manière don qui est capable aujourd'hui
d'aller regarder sous le capot des
algorithmes qui est capable de demander
des comptes aux algorithmes quice
qu'est-ce qui rentre dedans qu'est-ce
qui sort des algorithmes personne ne
fait du rettro engineering sur les
algorithmes aujourd'hui du rétro on en
fait mais typiquement monsieur conte
nous dit che qu c'est propre ou comment
on fait pour est- est-ce que la knil a
les moyens d'aller vérifier oui et elle
a numéro est-ce la a les moyens d'aller
vérifier pour devrai sans sa coopération
mais oui et une des dispositions que
j'aimerais porter c'est d'augmenter le
pouvoir de sanction de laacnil encore
une fois je je pense que le droit
pénal il doit être action en cas de
délit et de crime et que je suis pas
persuadé que ça soit un crime que
d'utiliser un algorithme de manière
erronée et que il y a une
réparation peut-être d'ordre civil et en
tout cas c'est ce que fait l'acnil hors
du champ régalier il y a a h hors du
champ des services de renseignement on
revient dans le champ civil d'accord ce
qui est quand même ce qui concerne tout
le monde au quotidien l'acnil elle
peut prononcer des sanctions contre une
entreprise qui respecterait pas les
données personnelles mais à hauteur de
150000 € aujourd'hui quand on connaît le
chiffre d'affaires de certains géants de
l'internet on peut estimer que c'est pas
beaucoup juste à titre de comparaison
non pas que j'ai spécialement envie de
les défendre mais bienp c'est biennp
pariba qui a été sanctionné aux
États-Unis pour noncformité au droit de
la concurrence américain ils ont été
sanctionné à hauteur de 7 milliards 8
milliards de dollars de dollars
américains donc le fait d'augmenter le
plafond des sanctions et de le lier au
chiffre d'affaires de l'entreprise ça me
paraît une alors neutralité des
plateformes est-ce que mais c'est
neutalité du net d'abord et non bah
j'allis le point de Benjamin c'était pas
le même moi je crois que c pas le même
c'est jeux mais je peux même répondre
c'est le point de Benjamin c'est de dire
si quelqu'un utilise des informations au
travers des services a priori c'est pas
pour lui vendre des voyage de vacances
on est rign non mais vous faites des
confusions pardon mais c'est quand
même
ce vous prvu
qu'oniss quand on parle des algorithmes
pour la détection de terroriste et c'est
ce qui est ce qui est en ce moment
discuté au Sénat on veut ESS deesserrer
pour essayer de détecter une personne à
par de
comp 2000 personnes en France ce dont on
parle c'est
une confusion qui est dangereuse moi
vous avez pas répondu à ma question si
j'écoute toute la journée du assassin et
que j'essaie d'aller chercher des
terroristes est-ce que je vais être pris
dans le filet mais bien sûr que non en
fait ce que pour moi l' l'enjeu
technologique c'est d'éviter les faux
positif connais l'algorithme c'est c'est
est pas dans la loi il est pas dans la
loi on sait pas ce qu'il y a dedans
c'est merci g lorsquon veut amélier la
rédaction de l'article pour limiter les
risques de faux positifs en limitant la
S veillance d'une seule personne plutôt
qu'un groupe de personnes en utilisant
des indices concordants toute une série
d'indices qui peuvent par l'algorithme
laisser à penser qu'il y a la volonté
d'organiser un attentat terrorist le
fait d'écouter de la musque qu'est-ce
qui me dit que dans assassin
l'algorithme n'a pas été paramétré avec
le tag assassin l'autre jour il y a eu C
sites qui ont été bloqués et on a appris
à postériori qu'un de ces sites c'était
un site musulman mais qui n'était pas un
site radical donc c'était écrit en arabe
il y a un fonctionnaire qui a pas
compris ce dont il s'agissait qui a dit
on interdit ce site là qu'est-ce qui
nous empêche que demain un fonctionnaire
dise croyant bien faire et bien je
considère que les gens qui écoutent du
rap un peu radical sont potentiellement
des gens qu'il faut surveiller pardon
Gill mais encore une fois tu fais une
confusion là ce dont tu parles les
blocages administratif de site pour
contenu illicite ça n'a rien à voir avec
la loi sur le sur les services de
bon c'est pas grave revenons à à à la
c'est de dire que les fonctionnaires
peuvent se tromper la CNCT et c'est
terrible parce que moi le le Premier
ministre parle de moi comme la gardienne
des libertés au sein de ce gouvernement
et il le dit comme ça pourci patr de la
commission parce que je me suis assuré
que au sein de la Commission nationale
de contrôle qui est encore une fois une
commission indépendante et des experts
et des experts ça veut dire quoi c'est
des gens qui connaissent les tuyaux et
les réseaux et qui savent comme vous
monsieur de quoi il parle de quoi il
parle et donc nommé par l'ARCEP qui est
une autorité administrative indépendante
qui est en charge de la régulation du
secteur des télécom ça me paraît très
important qu' des et la CNCT c'est pas
juste le collège qui va prononcer les
avis avant décision du Premier ministre
la CNCT derrière ils ont du backup ils
ont du personnel des experts et encore
des ingénieurs de réseau la CNCT elle a
un droit d'accès à4 he sur 24 lorsque un
algorithme est utilisé sur place chez
l'ébergeur pour voir comment il il est
utilisé ils ont euh au Sénat ce qui est
discuté en ce moment c'est que le champ
de l'algorithme soit réduit pour les
personnes visées qui soit réduit dans le
temps donc qui soit utilisable 2 mois
qu'au bout de 2 mois les agents soi
obligés de justifier les raisons pour
lesquelles ils l'ont utilisé et de
montrer si ça a été effectif par rapport
aux raisons je rappelle que les raisons
c'est la lutte contre le terrorisme
c'est pas écouter de la musique sympa
pour se faire plaisir non mais les
terroristes écoutent de la musique aussi
juste juste
juste attendez attendez attende pas tous
ensemble je voudrais juste revenir à à à
deux trois points de détail rapidement
intéressant ben je vais je vais en faire
un très vite tomber dans le simple et
cours ouais je vais en faire un très
très vite c'est économique ouais ques
sont les répercussionsc les américains
ils ont perdu 43 milliards alors qu'il
tenaent le marché et qu'il tiennent
toujours le marché 43 milliards en 2 3
ans de scandale 2 ans allez 2 ans 43
milliards de dollars d'impact direct ou
indirect très fort sur leur leur
stratégie nous j'ai pas vraiment
l'impression qu'on ait les moyens de
perdre ne serait-ce que 450 millions
donc premièrement mon problème il est
très simple moi je suis en Europe et je
suis installé en France je respecte
l'cneil depuis le premier jour je
garantis l'ensemble de de tout ce que je
dis et je vais même plus loin j'essaie
d'ouvrir tout en open source et c'est
très compliqué parce que moi j'ai un
algo qui doit enfin bon on en reparlera
plus tard donc je vais essayer d'aller
jusqu'au bout le problème c'est
qu'aujourd'hui si en Europe un ministre
là je parle plus d'un terroriste
allemand ou italien utilise mon moteur
de recherche moi j'ai garanti que je ne
traquais pas je n'ai pas posé de cookies
je n'ai rien fait que demain matin il se
retourne contre moi parce que d'autres
ont récupérer cette info alors qu'il
cherchait des choses pour ça peut être
un ministère intérieur d'un autre pays
vu que moi je vais pas le traquer au
moins chez moi il peut chercher
tranquillement sur Internet et que cette
info là est utilisé et qu'en fait on
remonte à lui et que lui trouve ça
scandaleux quelques part comme ça se
passe en ce moment avec de temps en
temps certaines écoutes ind direct qui
amènent sur des ministères au lieu
d'amener sur des terroristes comme par
hasard ma question est moi je vais avoir
un impact immédiat mais mais les gens
vont demander sur Twitter pourquoi je
garde mes frontes en France pourquoi je
délivre d'ici c'est arrivé mais c'est
déjà demandé regardez sur Twitter je
peux vous envoyer tous les tweets qui
m'arrivent pas un taux de croissance de
20 % mais simplement parce que et que
l'administration publique aimerait bien
commencer à utiliser qu en interne et
parce qu'on croit au modèle répond que
la loi aujourd'hui n'est pas passée mais
aujourd'hui les gens me demandent et moi
ma demande elle est pas de dire je m'en
vais ou je suis à droite ou je suis à
gauche m'a demandé de dire qu'est-ce qui
se passe pour se protéger d'une loie en
France si elle est mal
fermée par rapport à la demande
internationale qui va arriver derrière
mais faut lire la loi non si elle est
mal fermé aujourd'hui elle est
auattourer avec sincérité d'abord le
débat est pas fini j'insiste je je vais
arriver au bout mais comment je pe moi
je trouve que un c'est se tirer une
balle dans le pied et que si j'étais un
acteur économique je réfléchirais à deux
fois avant de le faire en comparant le
scandale le scandale révélé par Edward
sodden dans l'histoire de la de la ns
avec ce que seront en capacité légale de
faire les service de renseignement
français ça n'a rien à voir et de
laisser croire que c'est la même chose
c'est de se tirer une mal la chose c'est
la suivante si les gens s'inquiètent si
Benjamin qui connaît la loi par cœur il
est il sort même
'què tous les gens de ni pigon ni espion
s'inquièent c'est pour une seule
raison'inqu ils ont raison de
s'inquiéter dans le risque d'extension
pas aujourd'hui encore une fois je crois
qu'il il y a une petite erreur sur sur
le problème c'est que aujourd'hui on
nous parle tous de terroristes et et je
vois pas quelqu'un autour de la table
qui est pas d'accord de régler le
problème
terroristemor voilà non mais d'accord
enfin là je te parle de ceux qui
mett
vas-y des terroristes voilà je pense que
tout le monde veut régler le problème ma
question c'est voilà son problème c'est
qu'il se dit selon ce qu'il a lu lui
dans la loi il se demande si
l'épiciier pourrait pas être considéré
comme un terroriste et ça ça lui pose
problème et ça ça pose problème aux gens
qui se font justement des amalgam
sûrement mais les amalgames ça a coûté
43 milliards de dollars bon alors là
c'est sans amalgam parce que c'est vrai
qui traque mais aujourd'hui nous le le
truc est le suivant les répercussions
pour les RE la demande c'est les
répercussions économiques et le fait que
internet c'est mondial que c'est
européen déjà on va commencer juste par
l'Europe et qu'aujourd'hui on peut avoir
des répercussions qui viennent
d'ailleurs donc il faudrait que tout
soit clair même avec lescil il faudrait
que ça rentre même avec les knil et si
les knil peuvent se mettre dans dans ce
dispositif ça serait quand même beaucoup
plus simple et clair alors on va passer
on va passer à l'Europe mais juste avant
j'ai une question de jerémy Zimerman
pour vous qui est loin en ce moment mais
on l'a on l'a sur notre ordinateur je
vais vous le passer puis ensuite on va
commencer à parler de l'Europe avec Gill
Babinet
je vous passe Jérémie madame la
ministre on sait qu'avec l'espionnage de
masse c'est potentiellement tout le
réseau qui aujourd'hui se trouve être
l'ennemi du citoyen l'ennemi de
l'utilisateur on le sait aussi seul le
chiffrement de bout en Bou permet aux
uns et aux autres de protéger
efficacement leur
communication la tendance aujourd'hui on
l' entendu dans la bouche de Cameron
mais aussi dans la bouche du ministre de
l'intérieur casenu et de tenter
d'interdire le chiffrement ou encore
pire de demander au fournisseur de
chiffrement de le saboter pour laisser
au pouvoir public un accès outre le fait
que c'est complètement incompatible avec
la logique du logiciel libre à quoi
ressemblent vos réunions en conseil des
ministres et que dites-vous à vos
collègues sur le
sujet merci jérémy a le
ma je suis ravie que Jérémy me pose
cette question parce que j'entends la
tendance mais là moi je parle pas de je
parle de discussions interministérielle
de projet de loi qui vont être votés qui
vont entrer dans la vie des gens dans
leur quotidien peut-être que le premier
ministre britannique a annoncé un truc
jusqu'à preuve du contraire et il y a
preuve du contraire il n'y a rien dans
le texte de loi sur le projet de de
renseignement sur le chiffrement il n'y
a rien c'est un choix politique la
question s'est posée nous avons décidé
de manière collégiale et j'y ai
participé et j'ai donné les arguments
politiques technologiques juridiques
pour revenir sur le chiffrement parce
que nous sommes persuadés que c'est non
seulement inutile mais que c'est aussi
contreproductif
donc mais la question s'est posée donc
mais la question mais c'est d'une soit
vous êtes naïf soit vous êtes hypocrite
de penser que la question ne se pose pas
pour tous les gouvernements démocratiqu
élu qui font face à une menace
terroriste et qui ont des gens qui sont
quand même assassinés froidement dans la
rue je veux dire regardez les une
concernant les les et je veux pas tomber
dans la dans la dans la dans la psychose
et la paranoïa ça m'exaspère le le
climat sécuritaire mais on a quand même
une responsabilité pour protéger nos
concitoyens qui est
d'uneeur épouvantable et on on serait
irresponsable de ne pas se poser la
question de savoir voir quels sont les
outils technologiques à disposition pour
les protéger le mieux possible oui la
question s'est posée et oui la réponse
apportée par ce gouvernement c'est non
on ne revient pas sur les mesures de
chiffrement Éric cherer on vous a pas
beaucoup entendu non mais juste on on on
ouvre à l'Europe allez c'était ça un peu
que j'essayé tout à l'heure de de de
faire sur les sur les plateformes et sur
la neutralité du net je voulais savoir
où vous en étiez en ce moment en Europe
précisément parce que les signaux sont
pas très bons alors que pour une fois
les bons signaux viennent des États-Unis
sur la neutralité du Net
euh où est-ce que vous en êtes est-ce
que vous pouvez nous donner des
indications positives sur le fait qu'il
y aura pas un web à deux vitesses sur le
fait que cette neutralité du Net
apparaîtra dans le texte du Conseil du
du Conseil d'accord bon vous avez 3 heur
là parce que non il nous reste 14
minutes vous parliez de de plateforme
maintenant vous parlez des réseaux je
parlais de des réseaux et après bien sûr
esté par conse national du numérique qui
est intéressant au regard de la
neutralité du Net la raison pour
laquelle je je veux qu'on ait deux
concepts différents c'est justement pour
pas qu'on les mélange je parle de
loyauté des plateformes et je parle de
neutralité du Net parce que on parle pas
de la même chose quand et de parler de
loyauté des
plateformes et pas de neutralité des
plateformes ça veut pas dire que la
neutralité est moins importante ça n'a
rien à voir c'est juste de sujet bon
neutralité du net c'est vrai que je
trouve dommage que là aussi on laisse
entendre qu'en Europe et en particulier
en France on est moins avancé sur la
neutralité du Net qu'aux États-Unis
euh aux États-Unis il y a deux opérateur
télécom dominant ce qui explique que le
marché est très peu ouvert à la
concurrence qu'il est que les prix sont
très élevés de deux à trois fois plus
élevés hein pour prendre un abonnement
téléphonique et que le niveau de
couverture du territoire aux états Unis
est très mauvais et donc ça arrive très
très souvent de pas pouvoir passer un
coup de fil voilà et donc face à cette
situation le régulateur américain a
compris enfin que la neutralité du Net
non seulement c'était un principe qui
permettait de garantir un égal accès au
réseau pour tous que c'était aussi une
garantie de liberté donc il y avait une
valeur forte mais qu'en plus c'était une
garantie de liberté économique dans
l'accès et donc il commence tout juste
tout juste à faire de la régulation et
la régulation c'est pas un gros mot en
tout cas au sens où on l'entend en
France la régulation c'est mettre un
cadre qui permet à tous les acteurs
économiques d'être un equal playing
field donc d'être dans des conditions
économiques de concurrence égales et
transparentes ça ça c'est c'est le libre
marché c'est la concurrence voilà en
enfin en France et en Europe ça fait
quand même plus de 10 ans an qu'on a ce
cadre régul réglementaire concernant la
neutralité du Net moi quand j'ai été
nommée il y a 1 an je suis arrivée à mon
premier Conseil européen j'ai écouté les
27 autres pays et là j'ai fait il y a du
boulot parce que depuis celui qui était
ultra favorable à une affirmation du
principe de la neutralité du Net absolu
sans zéro exception sans dérogation
aucune à celui qui était juste
totalement opposé en disant c'est hors
de question euh les opérateurs doivent
faire absolument ce qu'ils veulent enfin
il y avait euh ouis c'était c'était
c'était impressionnant l'écart et donc
je me suis dit ici il faut absolument
avancer il faut absolument qu'on trouve
un accord au niveau européen parce que
justement les les les Américains en ce
moment s'affirment sur le sujet et c'est
quand même con que ça soit pas l'Europe
qu' fasse alorsù est-ce qu'on en est
aujourd'hui et donc moi je trouve qu'on
a bien avancé un an plus tard euh parce
que on n'est pas loin d'un accord euh
qui affirme le principe de la la
neutralité du Net et son importance et
qui alors ça mettrait du temps à donner
niveau détail ave qui laiss des pays
décider sur certains sujets des
exceptions et des dérogations concernant
les services spécialisés et je trouve
que moi je le vois comme une avancée
forte le fait que ça soit pas uniquement
la France ou d'autres pays de manière
isolée mais l'Europe l'ensemble des 28
pays de l'Union européenne qui puisse
ensemble affirmer ben le continent
européen c'est un continent
qui euh juste en debout c'est quoi un un
service spécialisé pour nous chez nous
en France ça peut être quoi par exemple
là c'est à vous de de de répondre ben ça
c'est un gros problème le service
spécialisé euh si minutes si tu enprends
ce qui se fait aujourd'hui sur les sur
les réseau c'est la télévision sur ADSL
et le téléphone euh qui sont les
services spécialisés cependant il y a
pas de définition légale du machin ça a
été un sujet de bataille homérique au
Parlement européen pour essayer de faire
comprendre au députés européens le sujet
et le problème c'est que si on autorise
des des dérogations pour les services
spécialisés sans mettre une définition
stricte des services spécialisés alors
on autorise une dérogation pour
n'importe quoi et on a perdu et je me
souviens très bien des amendements au
Parlement européen sur ce ce dossier-l
par que je l'ai pas mal bossé je me
souviens aussi des infos qui avaient été
envoyées par le gouvernement français au
députés français c'était quand ça euh
c'était à la fin de la législature
européenne précédente c'est-à-dire ou
j'ai une un piège un piège chopen ça
Contin un an et demi 2 an d'accord on
est quand là on est ENI 2015 on est bien
d'accord oui prendez vos prochains
Conseil européen on verra la position du
Conseil mais les les positions qui
étaient préconisées par la position du
gouvernement français a évolué sur ce
sujet d'accord ça c'est c'est une
information que je n'ai pas moi donc la
position du gouvernement français est
passé de plutôt pro service spécialisés
mal définis à une définition plus
stricte elle a plus évolué que ça et je
je je vous enverrai la position du
gouvernement français telle qu'elle
était à l'époque toujours est-il que
moi je veux bien qu'on entre dans une
définition européenne des services
spécialisés mais dans 15 ans on y est
toujours enfin il faut quand même là
aussi être un peu
réalisteend on aurait pu faire une
émission pendant 2 he mais je je vais
prendre les qu dernières minutes pour
moi donc ces 4 minutes pour clôturer ça
va être mon propre constat je je je vois
une loi de renseignement qui qui suit la
loi de programmation de renseignement
militaire loi loi de programmation
militaire nous faisons de la
géopolitique et de la géostratégie sur
notre chaîne YouTube nous recevons de
grands expert de la
géopolitique que ce soit au sein de la
DGSE ou des anciens de la DGSE ou des
Affaires stratégiques et nous avons un
point de vue un petit peu en recul face
à tout ça nous voyons une loi passer en
urgence passer dans l'urgence avec des
législateurs relativement faiblement
informé ou avec une compréélention
relativement parcellaire et nous on se
pose la question il y a eu beaucoup de
morts sur le terrorisme cette année du
moins par le terrorisme cette année en
France mais il y a beaucoup de morts sur
d'autres causes et les lois ne sont pas
poussées aussi fort aussi vite avec
autant de d'adhérence ou autant de de
parties pris ou autant de de de gens qui
votent derrière qui poussent donc nous
la question qu'on se posait
c'est les les les directives sont
vraiment très larges et on suspecte plus
cette loi de renseignement pour
contrecarré un climat de tension
économique grave c'est-à-dire une
ingérence au sein de notre économie
c'est passé c'est passé via via l'UDI
ils ont essayé de faire quelques petits
amendements donc j'espère que ce n'est
pas pour ça j'espère que c'est
réellement pour protéger d'une grande
menace un espèce d'améd de de jeun
moresemo j'espère que c'est c'est
vraiment pour nous protéger non pas pour
anticiper un climat économique d les
terres et que cette loi n'est pas là
pour faire du fichage généralisé je vous
invite honnêtement à lire la loi parce
qu'on est pas dans l'espoir là on n pas
dans l'espoir on est dans du très très
concret les négociations sur le texte
continue et moi je vais vous renvoyer
quand même à un question questionnement
qui est assez fondamental chez moi moi
je revendique pas d'être une
experte des réseaux non plus du
numérique je me suis intéressée à ce
sujet mais sous l'angue des politiques
publiques et qu' aujourd'hui constatant
que le numérique il avait une importance
qui dépassait la sphère économique c'est
devenu un sujet de société un sujet
géostratégique de économique un un sujet
de de rapport de force économique comme
comme de guerre
économique non pas de guerre économique
je je je j'aime pas le la terminologie
guerre économique il y a des rapports de
force économique dans le monde il y en a
toujours eu simplement aujourd'hui il
ils prennent une ils se traduisent dans
la sphère numérique et et et simplement
moi je je m'interroge sur la capacité du
milieu des
experts à s'ouvrir sur le débat public
et sur le grand public parce qu'en fait
en fait pour moi il y a aussi une une
incapacité à traduire en langage courant
à traduire dans les problématiques du
quotidien des enjeux qui sont sans doute
légitimes enfin des des des
questionnements qui sont légitimes une
expertise qui est absolument nécessaire
mais qui a pas elle-même fait sa
transformation à l'échelle des des des
de ce que représente le numérique pour
le quotidien mais avec aussi peut-être
une élite européenne voire française qui
n'a pas fait elle non plus non mais ça
je le constate je veux dire c'est vrai
du monde politique c'est vrai du monde
industriel c'est vrai du monde de
l'éducation c'est vrai du monde des
médias pardon de le dire mais de la même
enfin ça ça suppose un effort collectif
de compréhension des enjeux ça suppose
aussi d'essayer de comprendre la
technique ce qui est quand même
franchement pas évident et et moi ce que
ce que je souhaiterais c'est que tout le
monde le fasse cette effort c'estàdire
que tout le monde et et c'est pour ça
que cette cette initiative moi je l'ai
accepté c'est pas évident
mais mais parce que ça vu notre niveau
c'est sûr que ça vous change le Cabache
avec bibliothèque micis ah oui mais l
cabach avec bibliothèque mdicis il parle
à des millions de téléspectateurs
moi nous on parle à des millions de
téléspectateurs aussi sûr mais pas les
même moi mes sujets quand je me déplace
dans des campagnes dans des zones
péréurbaines où il y a des jeunes qui
ont pas de boulot c'est comment je peux
avoir accès à la couverture mobile
comment je peux avoir accès à Internet
et puis après je vais rencontrer des
jeunes surdiplômés qui font des start-up
et je vais leur dire ne partez pas dans
la Silicon valallleé on va s'assurer que
le pays est attractif faire venir des
investisseurs étrangers et puis on va
essayer de créer la grande école du
numérique pour que il y ait des jeunes
qui sont pas diplômés qui ont pas de
boulot qui puissent entrer dans une
formation courte
professionnalisante découvrir des
métiers géniaux qui sont des métiers du
numérique et trouver derrière un boulot
et puis il y a le président de la
République qui a qui annonce le plan et
éducation école tout le monde va
apprendre le code au collège c'est quand
même une bonne nouvelle on va enfin
former les profs qui seront plus
austracisés s'ils sont geek dans la
salle des profs on va diffuser les
usages numériques bref le numérique
c'est aussi ça et moi j'appelle à une
conscientisation mais plus large et
collective oui le PGL renseignement ça
pose la question fondamentale de
l'équilibre entre la sécurité et la
liberté dans notre pays et oui je
j'essaierai toujours de veiller à ce que
cet équilibre soit maintenu et pour ça
c'est un le débat public doit être
fourni enrichi vous y participez c'est
très bien le numérique c'est pas que ça
et il faut aussi que vous vous
intéressiez aux autres sujets on va
terminer là-dessus parce que Gill doit
nous abandonner je vous remercie tous
merci encore et excellente
[Musique]
journée